on the next Rick and Morty world ender
is back and this time he's out to end
more than world
it's Maximus renegade star soldier sorry
I'm late it was happy hour
I was also late because of my drinking
and mentioned it 2-0 applause catch a
new episode of Rick and Morty Sunday at
11:30 Marty right oh yeah
I never forget a kid what do you save
indicators let's make this three for
three oh three for three did you say he
never forgets a kin rick and morty doing
a straight-up Marvel movie parody this
is going to be so great so let's break
this down but it's actually the second
time that they've done any kind of
Marvel parody like a legit Marvel parody
if you remember during Total Recall
during season two they had to hold hands
musical reminds me of that time we all
got stuck in the elevator together you
remember that after the Hawke musical
buttons don't work better if you hit
them harder and foam fists don't make
you strong I know friends make you
strong I watched the same musical you
did why couldn't I bring my portal gun
oh why did all the drinks have to be
extra large oh the Hulk I just got that
into your pants I did it the minute we
got sick oh oh yeah yeah shame me at
least when I'm disgusting it's on
purpose Oh y'all we're gonna be fine
I've always been here for you guys and I
always will be haha still one of my
favorite episodes but in addition to
that you know even more marvel crossover
Dan Harmon legit wrote for the Doctor
Strange movie helped them punch up a
couple scenes I'll talk about that at
the end of this though but there's a new
round of the merch giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video so if you
couldn't tell this week's guest star
Maximus renegade star soldier is
Christian Slater maybe they'll be some
mr. robot references or some classic
Christian Slater movies from the 80s
he's done so many things that are worthy
of being parodied but he's sort of the
star-lord amalgam Iron Man character the
prototypical Marvel superhero that just
sort of stumbles into victory each time
through his redeeming qualities like he
doesn't think really stupid but then
somehow manages to save the day by the
end which is kind of like Rick he has
this towering intellect
winds up creating most of his own
problems that he then has to solve but
usually does so by choice in order to
avoid real-life problems like going to
therapy like turning himself into a
pickle
but in reality Rick is a superhero
character which is why it's kind of
funny they're poking fun at themselves
when Rick says I also mentioned that I
was late because of my drinking problem
to zero applause like it sounds like
he's really pissed and a little bit
jealous that Morty worships this
character that seems to have a lot of
the same qualities that he has even
though he's doing the exact same things
so it sounds like one of those
adventures where Morty would normally be
nagging Rick like why are you doing this
Rick this is wrong we shouldn't be doing
this but this time he's super excited
because he's with his heroes and Rick is
really pissed off about that I should be
your hero I'm the smartest person in the
room here but the title of the episode
Vindicator 'he's 3 return of world ender
is just a play on infinity war the third
Avengers film in their world and her
character probably in a Mogan for
Galactus the destroyer of planets I am
the last of our worlds
I require a herald to seek out new
products to pursue but most of you were
probably able to pick out which
guardians of the galaxy characters these
people are meant to be like this is
obviously their Rocket Raccoon only he's
an alligator this is their Drax only he
looks like he has kryptonite around his
neck this is their Groot except it looks
like he's made of mud or putty his face
actually looks pretty close to the face
of the original version of Groot it was
relatively simplistic compared to the
Groot of today but this actually looks a
little bit like the female star hawk
Elita or gourd she actually appeared
during the guardians of the galaxy to
post-credits scene in the comics she's
the wife of star Hawks 2-car played by
Sylvester Stallone so if you haven't
seen that be sure to go see guardians of
the galaxy I think they just released it
on home video today so you could
actually walk out and buy it if you
wanted to their logo is just upside down
Avengers a we saw some more footage of
them in the original season 3 trailer
where they're going after this actual
monster here it did look like a
guardians of the galaxy parody but in
reality it's just a parody of all big
Marvel sequels if you're a big fan of
Dan Harmon or you been following
instances community days you've probably
heard of the Dan Harmon's story circle
which is his way of breaking down the
Joseph Campbell motto myths in his
creative process for writing like how he
gives people prom
then solves them through the course of
their character development during this
other clip from the season 3 trailer
Morty runs into the garage and says Rick
The Vindicator 's need us all to
assemble by the educator I refuse to
answer a literal call to adventure let
it go to voicemail and when Rick says I
don't answer literal calls to action
it's sort of their way of making fun of
the copy-paste paint-by-numbers way that
a lot of these scripts for big Avenger
style movies get written but if you went
into the office of any writer in
Hollywood you would probably find a copy
of Joseph Campbell so if you feel like a
lot of big comic book movies or big
blockbuster movies feel like they're the
same the stories resemble each other a
lot it's because most of them are based
on the same framework so this is their
way of making fun of that as well as
making fun of a lot of Marvel specific
tropes so it'll be fun to watch this and
go back and say watch Avengers age of
Ultron I would actually recommend that
like after you watch this episode go
watch a big Marvel movie and see how
many things you recognize that they made
fun of during Rick and Morty but just
like normal I'll do my a straight video
on Monday so there'll be a lot of extra
fun stuff just because I normally do a
lot of comic book videos so this is like
the weird crossover where it all comes
together but as for Dan Harmon actually
writing on the Doctor Strange movie I
believe the scenes that he helped them
out with were during the Dormammu stuff
when he was going into the multiverse
because pretty much anybody in Hollywood
like I says have that just a Campbell
book they could write basic dialogue but
some of the things that Dan Harmon does
really well especially because of his
recent work on Rick and Morty is deal
with the idea of the multiverse so I
think that he helped them punch up some
of their really weird scenes like the
Dormammu I come to bargain scene her
mother I come to bargain
[Music]
for Mama
I come to bargain I don't actually think
that he's ever openly taking credit for
any that usually when writers go stright
or they do punch up on scripts they
don't talk about it because there was
another writer that did most of the work
and they want to give them the credit so
everybody let me know in the comments
what do you think about then doing a big
Marvel parody I think it'll be a good
episode anyway but it's just that much
more fun when you recognize a lot of the
Easter eggs like oh there's Galactus
their world ender and they got a bunch
of other high-profile guest stars so
we'll see if there's any others in this
episode because like they had both Danny
Trejo and Susan Sarandon and Peter
Serafinowicz in last week's episode so
it's not like they just have one special
guest star per episode but this should
be pretty fun so leave all your requests
for Rick & Morty bonus videos I've got
some new Game of Thrones I'll post
tomorrow and I'll say congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner astrak-- C
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details you can click here for
my episode 3 Easter eggs and references
and you can click here for brand new
Game of Thrones thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]